I had an awful battle the doctor set up
here was down to set my life is fragile
if I quit the game I can't repeat the
name it's what your head doesn't work
and everything will change
Zippity helping fields yeah that's what
I wanna be efficient hella tricky eating
some blueberries t crew what's good July
23rd Thursday hope everybody's
SuperDuper well big shout out to green
big shout out to Jamie Jensen Jenny B
what's good Henry Ernst zerah Garrett
Glen on Facebook great to see you as
well Sean stout on Facebook of the see
you Sam peach on Twitter easy-bake Eric
one what's good on Twitter day BW David
M excuse me on on YouTube what's good
Marsh makes comics great to see you on
YouTube where's my twitch squad and
where is my share squad before we get
into the show let's get some new peeps
with us here today share share woo
Dustin what Dustin you actually been
working sometimes you know sometimes I
decide to work what's that is that a new
update on stream yard no I just added a
gift we could add gifts so I just looked
up one and added it it's pretty simple
actually I'm very excited about this
well let's keep it going then if you
like the shear squad everybody's
watching right now if you share this
right now on Facebook twitch LinkedIn
Twitter please hit put in the comments
hashtag share squad that you shared so I
can give you some love Jessica C good to
see you
Tracey good to see you hey uh Dustin
sports cards are so craziest so somebody
put the comment in here
sports are so so crazy in a scrimmage
game yesterday a player by the name of
Bobo
his name is Bobo bol bol okay he's the
son of a basketball player from the 80s
that I grew up with called manu bull
who's like a seven foot six dude seven
six like a scheme and this Bobo but Bobo
skills are more advanced than his dad's
obviously you know that kind of happens
as dad was a raw talent just like this
super tall dude blocking
and he went crazy yesterday in a
scrimmage and his cards gone up like 4x
and I'm like oh my god have sports cards
got in this place we're like like
tonight's base baseball starts tonight
right mm-hmm and I'm just thinking like
if somebody hits two home runs tonight
this is like like I think the card
market has gotten so hot but there's
been no sports right so like what the
[ __ ] is gonna happen now now that
there's sports like I think just I feel
like everyone's gonna be on tilt so
learning worried about it actually
because I think a lot of people use
money because I'm gonna get into
gambling mode all right you know
somebody has two homers tonight and me
well the automatically think uh-huh
so anyway worried about that but excited
about that so nonetheless let's get into
the show cool berries and pears Nick hey
there how you doing yeah really good
really good to see you thank you so much
for having me of Cornell we had a bit of
great conversation the other day tell
everybody what you do so I've built the
first of its kind inland surf
destination in UK creates perfect waves
rolling down a field and the whole the
whole reason for it is around getting
people healthy happy communicating
better and for all ages all backgrounds
and all abilities
what's the website because what you've
done is remarkable you have a remarkable
story but I want everybody to check it
out what's the URL the wave calm so yes
you know yeah we're just getting ready
for reopening and so there's a few
changes just going through that but it's
obviously on handle I'm at the wave I
appreciate my friend what can I answer
for you and what can we ask the
community to help you with because you
asked for a little bit of context I just
just also to help people my voice isn't
brilliant at the moment because I lost
my voice I had a stroke a few a few
months ago and I lost every every single
word and I'm just rebuilding my my
and ability to converse so you'll have
to bear with me my voice is a bit clunky
at times noises amazing my man you're
amazing your face is amazing yeah I
really enjoyed it with you on social
cheers to you cool thank you so I'm just
a bit of context um so I I spent 18
years as an osteopath working in the
healthcare system and with my family and
particularly my dad and my wife and I
guess a moment a really important moment
was my dad died quite tragically with
from from cancer and it made me rethink
my whole purpose the whole reason why
I'm I'm on the earth really and then I
started to put together a vision of a
place a destination that people could
come and be healthy and happy
I love surfing I love outdoors so like
challenging the norm a bit and that's
when I started to come up with this
vision of the wave which is an inland
surf destination which is should bring a
huge amount of health and happiness to
people now you are you obviously through
you know adversity you created this
thing but you know what's really cool
about the wave when I hear you talk
about it is it's almost like you created
the the thing that you wish existed for
you when you fell in love with surfing
hundred percent hunting yeah just
literally just thought it almost like
going back to cartoons as a kid and
going if I could make the feature happen
how how would it look like and how would
we be as humans a lot of people asking
how much is a cost to build or two to
probably use I believe I it varies
between it would be about 45 to 50
dollars equivalent depending there are
different waves for different types of
waves for different people so the people
from absolute beginners right up to
professional
the way the wave I need is I'm gonna
like lay on the board like it's sledding
because I can surf and I need a very
small wave and I just need to be pushed
nice and exactly about my sports card
investments other people like you need
some off the coast of Portugal [ __ ]
right yeah exactly exactly so it's
something there for everyone
so I started this venture I had 500
pounds and we had to raise in the end 27
million pounds for it to happen and real
quick before we go to that part a lot of
people asking where is the wave Bristol
in the UK and we're also just about to
start a new one in London which is very
exciting because obviously it's it's a
phenomenal place London and very
connected to the whole of Europe as well
as the world but obviously I became it
became a bit of an obsessive legacy and
without a doubt my my parents my wife
and kids got the brunt of it a bit and
and I guess ultimately it led to because
I was getting really stressed we opened
in October and it was really great but I
think the the stress caught up with me
over 10 years of graft and that's when
you had your stroke that's when I had a
stroke which they still you were telling
me offline when we you know just for
everybody's context this is rare it
happened yesterday or tomorrow it's
happening today with Nick so maybe it's
not rare maybe it's emerging but you
know I'm a funny character I interact
with people and sometimes I just say yes
to things Nick and I'd were interacting
a lot on Twitter we just got into a
20-minute call and you want to tell me
about a story and it's struck with me
and I said let's get on the show tell
your story I want people know about the
wave and then we gotta get to a question
here before everybody punches you Nick
yeah no no I'm sorry but I'm but what
was what has struck with me was that
they still haven't figured out why and
and I believe what you believe I am
unbelievably intuitively I have no
scientific background I do not think I'm
an expert this is literally one human
beings under educated opinion
I am fascinated by what stress actually
does to the human body both to the
stomach and the brain and the heart and
I think it's gonna take a long time
before scientists really map this but it
is one of the biggest reasons why I want
people to have simplicity because there
are so many people right now stressed
about things they don't need to stress
that much when you when you were
building the wave in honor of your
father makes sense that that's stressful
I would also argue that the perspective
of the conversation of the stress of the
project the process of trying to do it
was the win not you actually
accomplishing it and people that are
go-getters thrill-seekers like yourself
a lot of times put pressure on
themselves that they don't need to yep
yep I think you've hit the nail on the
head and I think without doubt I created
a stress in myself which I just I just
didn't need to create that amount and
and you know a big reason why I wanted
to talk to you was around you know it's
a message that I really want to get out
there to people who are almost starting
in the journey or maybe in the middle of
the journey and want to make sure that
there's a reassurance that you don't
have to be so stressed to get through
that and to get that to that end point
is that you know a lot of the things
that you say which is around you know
but number one Family Matters I've found
out the hard way thank god my wife and
kids are still with me but I found that
out the hard way through that and I just
don't want anybody to go through that
again
and so what I'm so my ask I guess or the
question to you is I've got limited time
and resources at the moment you know
emotionally and physically and and I
guess like everyone else I don't
actually know how long I'm going to be
on this planet so I would love to get
your experiences to what I should to get
my message out there for people to
understand what we're doing
why we're doing it and also the way to
you know the way to do it as well
how do I get that message out there
because I can't be I started learning
yes why I'm doing this for you
yeah I starting like you know you know I
also think that people have a real
fascinating ego trait that I've always
thought a lot about because I'm funny
right because I come off with so much
for Votto but like but I think the
reason I'm sitting here today is when I
started on this journey of like I have
something I want to say and I think I
can help
I remember and I feel this way as I
speak to you Nick this morning if one
person is positively affected by it
mm-hmm that's a humongous accomplishment
and I think when I hear you ask that
question if you realized one person is a
massive win all of a sudden it doesn't
feel daunting to try to amass a million
followers that's true yeah I'd say
you're almost you know I don't want you
to do to yourself what you did with the
wave okay exactly exactly
yeah the answer is the process Nick yeah
yeah the process of trying to help
people and do good and we world
humanitarian that loves people yeah is
by a single action yeah and a single
person that's it brother yep that makes
sense that's it
put it out you've you've you've also
more questions thank you so much I love
you pal we'll talk soon
let's keep it moving yeah can't you see
can't you soon one person I know it's
like I just want to help but like cool
help one person yeah what they really
mean is they want to be verified on
Instagram and get brand deals let's keep
going hey Gary
hey Bry how are you I'm good I'm good
thanks for having me more importantly
thanks for doing this I mean you're
you're changing people's lives with the
show and and it's it's just awesome to
see thank you brother thank you for
saying that
yeah so my story is so I've spent my
career helping entrepreneurs scale and
build their businesses so I was part of
a three-person team that bought IMAX the
giant screen movie theatre company in
the early 1990s and
turned it into what it is today and then
about 12 years ago I moved from New York
out to Silicon Valley to be the chief
operating officer of coupons calm and
helped to build that from a start-up to
a public company as well so but I've got
two daughters my girls are now 14 and 12
and when my older daughter who was 8 I
watched her try to sell Girl Scout
cookies and run a charity bake sale with
a lot more enthusiasm than idea about
how to actually market and sell a
product I mean she didn't know like she
should say good morning to people when
she when they walked by to get her
attention and she didn't know that she's
a little people in the eye and all this
like basic stuff and that experience
combined with my frustration at what
I'll call some of the less than
empowering influences out there for
girls inspired me to write a novel
series to get girls interested in
entrepreneurship I love it
so I spent four of the hardest and most
humbling years of my entire career tana
rejection ton of failure learning how to
write for kids until ultimately I signed
a three book deal with Macmillan and we
just released our second book for you
thank you the goal and the goal here is
that every girl should grow up to be an
entrepreneur but they should have they
should be put into a framework of being
comfortable if they choose to through
their self-awareness that it feels like
a comfortable option instead of being
just a voice
absolutely but more importantly that
they have that untrue mindset that they
see opportunities instead of problems
and are comfortable with risk and
comfort with failure and all those
things you get from just even like a
simple Lemonade Stand you learn this
mindset that's gonna help them succeed
in life regardless of what they want to
do I mean my great love affair with
entrepreneurship is the relationship
with losing that it creates especially
in this environment I knew believe this
generation of parents over the last
fifteen to twenty years and the it has
really demonized losing so much and
overprotective children that we have an
entire generation of Millennials and of
course a small percentage or a
percentage of them you know that really
are scared of failing and I think you
know I would argue one of the great you
know I've had this conversation with a
lot
of incredible women and men that
entrepreneurship in at a young age is
one of the greatest preparers for
motherhood uh-huh yeah you know it's a
it's I think what entrepreneurship does
is gets people comfortable with losing I
really did that so it's funny you say
that because one of the things that I
when I talk to kids that I talk to
schools and libraries and Girl Scout
troops and all those sorts of things is
I say that if you ever heard the
expression win some lose some
entrepreneurs don't say that
entrepreneurs say win some learn some
yeah and I take them through how
important it is to fail and I should
tell them what's beautiful is you talk
about like the things that you fail at
and no one watched this video people see
put these people up on a pedestal and
they don't know that like Beyonce you
know lost at Star Search when she was in
99 years old and Bill Gates his first
company went over and Michael Jordan got
cut from his high school basketball team
and all these things like you know
failure happens but it's how you deal
with the failure that determines you
know how you're gonna succeed and deal
with things in life yet to me like to me
I actually prefer failure I'm not even
you learn the talent like micro failure
I'll be honest with you
I'm a big fan of the learning part I'm
with you on that I just actually like
the motivation of it I like a an
adrenaline like I like what I'm put in
my place
Bry yeah you know like I like when I'm
like I don't what's like like like I
like that calm I do it with myself all
the time because there's always micro
losses and everything I'm doing I'm like
see you think you're so like I the talk
with myself of like oh you think you're
so fancy people like you and think
you're smart you [ __ ] suck like I
love that but but that's not beating
myself up and being depressed that's you
know humility I love humility I think
it's attractive yeah I had in this
writing journey I had one editor of the
publishing house tell me am i writing
for kids was so bad she was surprised to
learn I actually had children yeah man I
mean you should have seen the articles
written when I started vaynermedia one
was called Twitter boy thinks he can
stop a meetin see you
I get it so what can I answer for you
alright so here's the question so the
target audience for the books is let's
say 7 to 13 year old girls so based upon
what you learned with little V and other
kids stuff that you've done how much
should I be balancing my marketing
between the parents and the kids and
what are the best channels to reach
those two audiences 70% parents go heavy
on Facebook I think Facebook groups
Brian you clearly based on your pedigree
you spend 5 to 10 hours studying
Facebook groups and you know what to do
as soon as we hang up here you go to
Google Facebook groups start reading
everything watch some videos listen
however you learn Facebook groups
Facebook targeted ads an Instagram
targeted ads Instagram story swipe up
ads that go to your Amazon landing page
right know 70% of that energy 30%
tik-tok influencers at scale whoever can
give you the best deals that would be
how I would mark in this book I'm sorry
one last thing I would look at other
books that speak to you know you know
young women girls around stem and other
advancements I would look at those books
I would then run YouTube pre-roll ads
and you're gonna re-watch this because
the details but yeah YouTube pre-roll
ads against people searching those books
so I would map the 70 most successful
books that are taught in the last two
years three years five years that have
targeted your audience you can take that
as a cluster on Google searches and then
the people that search that on Google
when they go to youtube to watch a
makeup tutorial video will get served
your pre-roll based on the fact that
they searched that or a brought maybe
those 70 book titles will give you a
broader look cuz it's too narrow those
would be the tactics I would also reach
out to 500 different parenting podcasts
and just ask to be on the show
don't let six or seven placements it's
just hustling yeah yeah all right one
yeah we are I want all girls to have
this on trial mindset not just those
you can afford to copy the book so I'm
working with the charity girls Inc of
New York City and we're donating copies
of the book to their girls my free we've
raised enough to donate 7,000 copies of
the book to their girls but we want to
get to 10,000 how much does it cost per
book
so it's $4 tax-deductible donation to
throw I mean I'm in right now for 4,000
for another thousand books awesome thank
you so much and anyone if anyone else
wants to do it a hundred inspiring one
one hundred inspiring one hundred calm
what is that I want to make sure that be
one hundred inspiring one hundred
comm100 the number inspiring 100 the
number calm exactly and you can make a
tax-deductible donation if a girls
saying four dollars puts the book in the
girl's hands and maybe changes her life
thank you awesome thank you I when you
are gifted when you are fortunate you
can do anything you want with your money
and your time I don't think anybody
should do anything who gets to decide
what [ __ ] is but boy is it fun to create
good all right let's keep going
Candice hey Gary how are you I'm well
how are you and thank you so much for
having me on I'm really excited to be
here I've been following you for about
two years and this past year I've been
really working on implementing the
strategies that you've been suggesting
so to give you a little background I
have a side hustle I'm then wanting to
turn into a full-time business within
the next like one to two years it
focuses around bridging the gap between
college education and career readiness
for young women in college and recent
grads and it's called happy professional
I published a book about two years ago
and it's a guy that helps students like
create achieve their dream career and I
went to a college fair like pre Colvin
and I got good feedback from like
counselors and students saying that it
would be beneficial for their students
although I didn't make like a lot of
sales at the college there they still
thought I'd be helpful and then as far
as like social media goes I've been
doing like Twitter Facebook
YouTube and then was like LinkedIn i
implemented your what-if strategy that I
saw you mentioned on one of your other
I'm team Gary B and then I did I started
the community group community text from
your text messages that you sent out I
ended up signing up for it so as far as
like what my question goes to is I've
heard you mention sometimes people say
that you might say the same thing and I
feel like I can fall under that umbrella
because my content is evergreen as far
as like how to create a resume cover
letter setting goals the time is the
truth okay like I just think that what I
do well as I say the same thing in
different ways in different places and
different formats with different context
right that's like questioning like howdy
yeah I'm very good I'm just like how do
you stay creative when you're sharing
evergreen content when you're putting it
out I'm still being able to and this is
very interesting point
I got Dustin get in here real quick when
you join the team yeah you know I like I
always think that what somebody joins up
my team the thing that they're most
surprised by is how creative I actually
am great mm-hmm would you agree with
that test yeah you always have ideas I
think because you you're like better at
just like not thinking or inside the box
right I live in a different more text
yeah where we're trying to like we're
like overthinking sometimes Oh Candace
listen listen this is why I need that
would bring value here you by the way
Candace you might not be creative and
that's okay because there's incredible
people in the world like this guy yeah
might team up with you we're sharing the
revenue of the book or you may not be
creative today because you haven't
trained yourself and maybe you work for
a year to get more creative or pay very
close attention to what Dustin has said
I'm not scared
which is why I'm creative I don't
overthink I don't give a [ __ ] alright
don't overthink because I don't give a
[ __ ]
this is what people get confused I'm
compassionate sympathetic and empathetic
about people when I say don't give a
[ __ ] it's not because I'm so cool I
don't give a [ __ ] it's that I can't give
a [ __ ] cuz I'm not in control people
play with perfection because it's their
insecurities then they put it out it
doesn't work well and they shut down the
reason I'm thinking outside the box like
doesn't just said is I know that I'm not
in control
thus I can't even walk thus I just
communicate what I feel at that moment
some things work some things don't
pattern recognition takes over I
eventually figured it out because then I
listen after I put it out cuz that
community's not just there to [ __ ]
service me with [ __ ] likes and
follows it's the according to get better
and I listen I read I listen I read I
listen read or do ideas come from
listening and reading cuz I put in the
[ __ ] work I to think that you know
like it becomes real life I know that
are you
I knew Dustin would say something smart
without even realizing he said something
smart I am not scared to put out content
that actually helps us because uh since
you're like since we're pretty much not
scared it allows us to kind of just
really okay we'll just do whatever we
want and then see what like get more
creative by allowing pretty much
allowing us to be more creative because
there's no rules essentially right
there's a lot of people that try to
build teams like team of Gary Vee and
they don't work because the leader she
or he is deeply insecure and tries to
control everything and then it just
becomes one big circle of non making and
politics and emotions and frustration
I'm the reverse they get weirded out
mainly on the fact of how little I give
a [ __ ] when it's actually me the human
the contents me and I'm like yeah
whatever yeah go write dust I mean I'm
sure that took some time to actually
believe me right yeah but just not to
care just put it out and they need to
step back and spend time to not to care
means something very different than what
most people think that right I mean
that you want to find what works instead
of having the ego or insecurities of
thinking you know what works okay and so
now you're putting out stuff to see if
it actually brings value and this is
your hype I never think I'm right
I just missus I'm being serious
I never income right I just have a
intuition hypothesis curiosity to see if
I'm right you decide right it seems it
right and to put that out like I'm a
skill on all the channels yes just then
see what works
of course because the channels are how
people see stuff it used to be these
papers different newspapers New York
Times also generally a post-match a wire
you know gossip used to live on National
Enquirer and Us Weekly now lives then it
lived on Perez Hilton and Just Jared how
it lives on your Instagram feed the
channel changes the game does it okay so
that helps I think I need to take back
and like process that and figure out how
to like execute on that successfully but
I did have another question and it's
around like revenue streams so I'm
creating in a cap since I do want to do
it full-time like within next one two
years and I'm creating an academy around
the book and it was going to be a
monthly subscription where it allowed
them to have access to me monthly for
question answers but I've watched your
videos where you said don't charge for
information charge for access so I want
to make sure that I'm providing value so
would you recommend charging for the
Academy give it for free and I mean
another product to sell I mean instead
you could do whatever you want
a couple things scare me one when I hear
in one to two years it gets really scary
because then you get impatient so you're
putting a topping limit on this which is
batting number two you know whether
you're giving away for free
already charged for it people have to
value it exactly okay you know to me
I've spent fifteen years giving away
content at this point
for free and so people value me because
I brought the value and then they would
consider having a transaction with me if
I would do that I don't know how much of
a community at reputation a real thing
that you've built that will lead to
people wanting to do that with you right
I'm still growing like my audience I'm
like my audience is under a thousand I'm
just like the experience that I've
gained I feel like I've been fortunate
gained experience I don't feel like a
lot of people my age are like younger
than me have experience so that's what
I've been wanting to share which is in
the book through like internships
without remember this the second you go
to monetize your audience the
relationship yeah has changed right okay
so what do they pay which is okay yeah
look yeah you know I can sit here like a
big shot and say don't charge if if I
make six straight years of terrible
decisions and have no revenue stream and
I feel like the only thing that's left
is my community and I've got to go from
doing all of this to starting something
that I charge for access you know two
hours a day with me a month and people
pay for that no more this kind of free
stuff it's all behind you pay well like
animals have to survive you know I I
don't think I'm gonna get to that place
but like there's nothing wrong with
charging for information or access the
question is is a valuable compared to
what they can get and and if you can
trick them with [ __ ] YouTube
pre-roll ads does that eventually run
out once you don't have the meat behind
it and it becomes a short term win
there's so many hustler 25 year old
[ __ ] you know guy character versions
of me that make money for a year and
then lose it all right right but if I
like eventually do want to go off on my
own
likes have my own business or I want to
scale this to be profitable like would
you what would you like recommend both
where I don't work you give in a way
they have for free and then selling
something else getting that wasn't
speaking for public that's what I did I
didn't my enticements i monetize the
fact that I had brand out there and
people were interested in me
then a cut you know conferences and book
companies came along and there was
monetization against that okay you know
or you charge 500 bucks a month to get
access to you and you get five people at
first and you live humbly at two
thousand dollars a month and you just
keep building yeah you're right okay
awesome
good luck thank you you're welcome share
share share where's the share squad keep
it going cool man oh man is right David
how are you um better than I deserve how
you doing you deserve to be even better
than you think
well maybe um I I do have a question
but I wanted to start by just saying
like I've been watching you for a long
time since the Wine Library TV days a
friend of mine actually got me onto you
and you know just the way you made
people appreciate and gave people
permission to not fit the mold it was
just awesome like what what do you like
about this one it tastes good that's
enough of a reason you know that's super
very I can't think it's cool and you
know you talked a little bit about the
The Charlatans thing like people think
Darren and I actually had some people
that I trusted very much and I still
trust like a lot as people and they see
you as that and so that kind of like and
it's alright like cuz in my mind kind of
made me look at you closer and be like
yeah they just you know it's funny when
people have a negative view on me I
never get upset because I know what my
personality vibes are and I know my
jersey nests and like theirs right I'm a
raw character and it's in your face and
I'm high-energy and I curse I never ever
get upset nor do I judge those
individuals they rightfully so cuz
everyone's busy have not spent the three
four seven hours where it becomes wildly
obvious what's going on here and I
appreciate that I don't think I don't
have enough ego to think that everybody
should be spending all this time
figuring me out the truth always wins
and david and that's the thing you know
even the cursing kind of like rub me and
i'm like but why like why does this
bother me and it doesn't anymore like
i'm fine with it and so it's just me
it's to your point cursing i love people
that take the high road with me like
through the years who ended up being bad
people and doing real bad things and
they would spend their time you know
leaving comments on LinkedIn or Twitter
about me of my cursing only to be found
out that they were fraudsters or sexual
predator I mean it was just like
fascinating to watch and I think a lot
of people cast judgement are doing it to
deflect what they're actually up to and
and so for me because I was watching
more closely I just
I see the goodness you know I thought I
agree with so many of the things that
you say like being debt-free and school
great if school is great but it you
don't need it and you know find ways to
kind of find your path and I've always
liked wonder you're so giving giving
giving giving a calculative back to this
guy what can I offer you and you've said
in previous episodes you don't need
anything like what's the ROI on tea with
Gary Vee and I just don't see it but I
did want to I do want to give one shout
out if I can before I get to my question
whine text is my favorite thing like I
freaking love wine text and I'm and so I
mean I have wine here like my whole
collection of wine is just stuff that
I've got from from wine checks
thank you mom you know how that reads he
cool is that service like how easy is
that the last which is insane right it's
so amazing like the only thing I've to
do is be here to sign for the thing when
it shows up you know and I'm not the guy
that looks at the hundred done $25 wine
that I can get for 50 bucks which is a
spectacular deal but I'm the guy who
looks for the stuff that's under 15 you
know I didn't know I was so disclose oh
yeah that was 30 minutes but I mean I've
got this Cabernet and then because of
you like I've been looking at these
whites you know I'm not a white wine guy
but every one of these bottles of wine
is just one thing you and what's really
fun like I'm not I'm not the guy
that this one is super cool too unless
healthy it was awesome
in fact I think I bought this one twice
what am i that the first time we did
that it was like we did something crazy
with that one because I just wanted to
freak people out
yes this one was nuts it was like seven
and eight dollars ladies cents or
something it was an insta buy for me I'm
not the kind of guy that will go into a
store and look at the wines and figure
like I don't know anything about where
they come from or what they do
somebody's got to recommend something
and so the fact that this you guys would
recommend one and I know this isn't
helping you this is your dad's business
but I love every one of these resonate
listen the my dad getting benefit from
this it speaks listen me David I was so
lucky with the DNA I was given I will
never ever need anybody watching this or
anybody ever watching me in my life I
will never need to do anything to trick
that person into giving me money because
I'm so capable of making money with my
hard work and talent no doubt when my
dad benefits from lying texts it feels
better than when I benefit when I get
the 500 emails I'm getting a week right
now from people who literally make tens
of thousands of dollars in sports cards
nothing to do for me it feels remarkable
when I say one thing on this show that
leads to somebody you know HAP being
happier because they see the world
differently to me when you actually are
an empath when you actually are
structured that you get great joy out of
admiration or other people succeeding it
just becomes your state of being I just
happen to be packaged as a business
alpha-male which is unusual because you
know by the way society thinks it's
supposed to be I'm supposed to look like
a 54 year old grandmother's and out
meditating and you know in the hills of
you know South America but it's just who
I am and so you know you're being very
kind right now and I appreciate when
you're doing and it makes me happy
because I know that some people going to
sign up for wine Tech's right now my
dad's gonna be pumped that makes me
super pumped if it's the if it's the
only thing I can do
super more than you getting all 10,000
people are watching right now the sign
for wine tax when you talk to those
people that say I suck or I'm just out
it for me when you actually say hey I
love you and we are real friends for 20
years but it's only because you haven't
dug in that's doing more for me than
everything else combined because it
feels nice to have a friend that stands
up for you I mean here should pull off
like your book got your first book and
the first thing that was in here was
like chapter 9 is my favorite thing the
greatest Marvel read in any book ever
everybody I'd almost been here chapter 9
it's annoying right here this is way
deep in the book yeah and it's the
greatest marketing strategy ever right
here it is that's the title chapter
that's the title of the chapter and you
turn the page and it is exactly one word
care that's a greatest marketing
strategy and now we move on to chapter
10 like there's an entire chapter in
your book dedicated to one word and if
more people got on board with that the
world would just be a better place just
care about people and to story to me
will stop everything that's going on in
society and conflicts in business and
politics in our culture I I've gotten
into more deep conversations and more
tense conversations with loved ones
friends business associates in the last
hundred days and what what a lot of my
individuals that I've spoken with have
learned for me is kindness to me is a
line in the sand I'll pay a hundred
percent taxes right but kindness is a
non-debatable
play for me period even the people that
I've seen it's so good I've seen
snippets of you in somebody coming and
saying I don't know how to do this I
don't honor this and you're like just go
do and it's like the way you deliver the
hard message is with timeless and I love
that I appreciate it and but but as you
know and the people watching know some
people can't see the second layer of
what I'm doing they see it as me being
mean because
I'll curse or I'll come at it like with
a certain kind of like you know it's
kind of like like it's amazing how many
people are do not have strong intuition
or understanding of people it I
understand it and I just stay consistent
and do what I need to do well you're
crushing it
so thanks somebody in there said that
they didn't happen yet you somebody in
there said that they didn't know you had
a blind eye record so here's where I get
real and I didn't really want I don't I
debated even coming and talk to you
about this and I've run through this a
hundred times but I have been dealing
with some issues in my life that are
very very difficult and you know I'm on
the back side of that but the
ramifications so I you know I used to be
really kind of vocal on on Twitter
especially that was kind of like my spot
and you know tried to dabble in all the
others I've got a tick-tock account that
has like five videos on it or something
but Instagram and I went through I got
married and then I went through a very
very very difficult divorce for four
children involved for four to forty yes
I had five kids four of them were from
this marriage and so because of the
nature of this divorce like I'm I felt
like in order to protect the children
and the future that we had like I had to
kind of back away I didn't get to tuck
my kids into bed for four years and so
you know all of that is over but you
know I basically went into hiding and
some circumstances happened that my
church asked me to leave and understand
like I'm not upset about my church I
love the people I love the church and I
love all that stuff and I'm super
thankful for everything I've been given
but there's still this this healthier
yeah like like what can I can I get back
out there and beasts and do it safely
and protect my cousin
my family's number one man I married
I have an amazing wife she's actually
listening to this right now hi I dig it
you know this because you've clearly
followed me super super closely you're
in control of what you put out
I sure nothing about my kids I noticed
that I know I know that you don't like
you trying to know what your wife hurts
like that's right if the Google result
is wrong it's that like from you that's
how private I am and so you know I think
good news of course you can go out there
you are in control of what you say and
what conversations you get involved with
and that's that I mean it's I knew was
gonna be that simple but I've just I
have this like I want to be authentic
and real and no but I sure don't put on
a show be authentic and real in
categories that you're willing to be
authentic and real in right like right
what I think you're missing here is you
don't have to be in every conversation
and I'm definitely not nor am i I stay
very narrow okay you know and that's it
you go into the Congress mean I mean you
should see what's going on in the sports
card conversation I mean a lot of
percentage of that audience doesn't like
me coming because they think I'm
bringing the prices up and I don't
really care about it like you know like
any conversation you go into you're
gonna have judgment sure but if you come
with good intent it all plays out in the
end but there's people that don't even
do social media cuz I carry I don't want
my [ __ ] out there I'm like then don't
post it so close to right right so you
know I get where you're going there's
there's plenty of subject matters that
you don't want to get them you know in
maybe you don't get into conversations
around divorce you know online you know
I think don't be
I never fear not being authentic cuz I'm
always authentic I just don't go into
combos that I don't feel like I know
what I'm talking about or that I don't
want to share because I'm private yeah
yes I mean I can relate to so many of
the people that you've had his guests I
mean you had Diana back up last week and
like she you know she's a procrastinator
because she's you know
wanting to be perfect and so I want to
put out the right content and I'm like
well do I say it this way or do I say it
that way and you're you're always saying
put out the junk and I'm just like that
just freaks me out putting out the trash
it freaks me out
it freaks you out because you value the
judgment too much maybe you got it it's
also what not beautiful right like when
you go through something like that and
you give me some context there's a lot
of judgment that comes along without
without full context and saying I this
that makes people retrieve you know
there's so many people I mean people are
struggling right now because we have
cancelled a mob culture people are
judging everything you know you know one
of our political parties sells fear the
other one sells shame it's it you know
at the extremes it's very very very very
difficult but and I'm I'm worried that
somebody's gonna see something and go oh
well I'm gonna use that against him and
it's like you know I don't want to live
in that fear then then don't put up
don't get involved in things that could
lead to that say things you believe in
and stay in conversations that you're
comfortable and it's why I don't go into
health care conversations or how to
build bridges or I don't talk about
cryptocurrency people want me to talk
about a long time I've got my little
base of knowledge you know I invest in
Bitcoin a long time ago and so kind of
did well but like you know have not
stayed up with it blockchain things that
nature
I actually know quite a bit cuz even me
not staying up on it the way I roll
probably has like I watch people talking
that clean literally and their thing
said cryptocurrency experts and I even
know what they're saying is wrong you
know the sports card thing I studied for
a year before I started putting out
content and I was in that business for
11 years of my life and deeply I'm
involved in sports I know what I'm
talking about I you know you know and so
stay in what you know and say what you
mean and people using it against you can
only beat I mean listen David we have
something we have a technology called
deep fake do you know what that is
yes I do yes when we're gonna live in a
world in 15 years where people are
making people gonna have me in this
video say something I didn't say because
the technology is that advanced people
are not going to even believe in video
it's good we're gonna have to
have been a very different world like a
real self self love and compassion
because people are chipping away and are
trying to divide and what we need to do
is come together and I'm just very
I'm just very not interested in judging
people because I know we don't have all
the context and I'm very interested in
loving people until proven otherwise
and I'm compassionate and empathetic and
sympathetic and I don't need any
validation from anybody I'm in my own
cocoon and and that's what you need to
practice to get to period of the story I
mean that you if you know who you are
and your children know who you are and
your loved ones know who you are who
gives a [ __ ] with Sammy pants ninety six
things you just kind of have to get
there brother and I know that through
parenting and high school and life that
95% of people watching right now do get
feel things when somebody says bad
something about them I'm just trying to
teach them how not to and it starts with
it actually starts with not getting too
high in reverse what people don't
realize about me is like when you
started saying all those nice things I'm
getting I get a little shy believe it or
not like I really I'm aware that I've
got good stuff going on I don't need it
I don't need the accolades which is why
I'm not vulnerable to the criticism
right oh yeah I just need to I just need
to maybe laser focus and I mean like
your last guest you know Candace she's
not she says she's not creative I'm not
creative either but I am a Jedi Master
copy and paste and so I know I see what
you're doing copy and paste your way
into happiness and recognize that you
went through a shitstorm for four or
five years how much worse is gonna be
don't be scared yeah cool man thanks so
much for everything you do I appreciate
it seriously Cheers
somebody said it's hard to be very nice
it's so funny Chris Vargas pin this one
Dustin I couldn't I couldn't disagree
more Chris and what I mean by that is
it's actually very easy to be very nice
you just have to love yourself first
because when you're nice and it's not
reciprocated you can't take it personal
you know I think it's stunningly easy to
be nice because I don't think the world
owes me anything I don't think any human
owes me anything and I think that when
people let me down that's their loss not
mine I really believe that [ __ ]
let's keep it moving hey morning Gary
morning brother how are you I'm happy
how are you doing I'm happy too what's
good AJ I don't know if you recognize my
face but about a month ago I made a
tick-tock of me putting you in a Jets
uniform you put on your Instagram story
bro it was dude that was so well done
thank you thank you what incredible I
was blown away by that and as you know I
don't share that I mean I get so much
stuff made about me
and I get 5 million Jets things made
about me agenda that was so well done
you're talented bro thank you thank you
yeah so actually that was my job for
about three years was work for the
Nebraska football team putting recruits
and uniforms and stuff like that so I
was super happy to do it I was talking
about that they can sign exactly so yeah
let me tell a little bit about me
so I'm 22 and Lincoln Nebraska and
actually just graduated this past
semester thank you I'm a graphic
designer and illustrator one of them
being Sports design so kind of similar
to the one the thing I made for you but
the primary form I do a lot of outdoor
design so the Patagonian North Face type
shirts you see logos and stuff like that
so big passions of mine are just you
know helping out and loving people but
also the environment but anyways so I
graduated and you know in this crazy
time I was trying to find motivation and
my brother Justin recommended me to
crushing it and so you know I'm one to
find the goal and kind of chase after it
once I have it and kind of halfway
through reading the book I kind of just
put it down and I made a tick-tock you
know got to like posting six times a day
and that led me to kind of have this
cool series where every day I was making
a shirt as if I were working for a guy
or you know if North Face and got a
really cool response out of it
they both got around a million views and
it was awesome so yeah before I go into
my question I want to tell you a little
more bit of a more I had this other
concept that created eyes called NFL
nature week and so I kind of wanted to
combine both of my passions and the idea
I essentially had so I actually
redesigned every NFL teams logo in kind
of an outdoor style and I did that I
made a peril I did this for all these
teams and the idea would be that they
would wear these sell these out to fans
and then raise money for a national park
in Milan I love that's very clever in
that you know team state so be kind of
stable I get it okay so I've been trying
to kind of push that out and I've kind
of been I've been really blessed and
happy lately I've been getting a lot of
good responses and you know making out
taking on cool projects and stuff like
that so essentially my days look like
you know I'll post content for myself so
content you know I have stickers right
here but you know stuff like this where
I'll make and you know sell shirts and
stickers and stuff so I do all the
inventory for that I ship everything
along with that I'm doing freelance work
who's living it know you're anxious you
like what you do you're in the [ __ ]
zone yeah and I took your advice to I
started doing a free online zoom drawing
class and it's been cool to kind of have
and act like I'm a teacher and know what
I'm talking what I like well you do know
what you're talking about because you're
living it you don't need credentials I
like that you're playing high and low
right you're creating these what-if
scenarios that are getting attention for
the biggest companies in the world and
you're in the trenches giving back
you're winning you're playing a little
bit you're getting very real and close
to my framework keep going yeah so I'm
doing that I'm doing the class right I'm
pitching NFL nature week talking to a
couple teams about that trying to get it
off you know talking to big brands like
you said and so
and so another plug with tick-tock I
posted tick talked about the shirts a
while back and took the Patagonia off
you know replace the text and sold the
shirts and my couple orders I did a
while back I got maybe 50 orders and
right now I'm sitting at like 400 so
it's it's crazy and I'm gonna need a lot
of help shipping out those shirts
because it's literally just me so my
question is more you know being able to
be smart with my time like you know I
can't go full force in a whole you know
all of these things have to hire when
that's possible given kovat okay right
right now I would tap into relatives
okay yeah so my mom yeah my mom and dad
my you know my whole family were super
close and they're really happy to help
Timmy and put your mom to work and if
you haven't have some younger cousins or
nephews or nieces or even a best friend
this is the time family life yeah no
absolutely and that's definitely
something I've thought about your spray
like your best friend sleeping in your
room after quarantines for a couple
weeks like make sure your family feels
right or however you guys see the world
with that yeah no absolutely I so I live
three other guys and yeah they're happy
to help too so so I don't know I mean
you're you look at three other guys yeah
dude you're sad we course these guys
into can we pay them and have them help
yeah absolutely
that's called scaling a business let's
[ __ ] go yeah so of course you bro you
should not ship a single thing you need
to design you're the talent
I shipped boxes for Wine Library I
shipped the first 5,000 cases of wine
that shift out of winelibrary.com in
nineteen ninety seven eight nine ten you
know and then there was enough money to
hire somebody yeah I mean so for me I do
all the inventory and you know ship all
my stickers so I'm shipping you know
probably 50 letters every week and
having to do that and which kind of
leaves me a new question is like you
know oh delegating and giving
responsibilities
other people when you first started was
that it was easy because I wasn't scared
cuz I knew I could say I'm sorry that's
good
ya know one of my biggest okay I didn't
get here by accident of course it's good
[ __ ] no but really I get it I
can see her notice how my aunt you know
what I like about how I see the world
it's all context I can see you're a
sweet soul I'm a sweet soul that's why I
see it I'm like oh I know this guy's
problem if he doesn't know what I know
which is I'm sorry is unbelievably
powerful my biggest fear is like
shipping something out I'm not getting
it you know thinking I'm too back yeah I
literally drove a case of $20 white
zinfandel in a snowstorm during the
holidays because it was the right thing
to do yeah and quite honestly you know
with my question of all these
responsibilities and things I want to do
you know one of my biggest stresses is
like the more people that are looking at
my stuff you know I want to respond to
people like you respond to people and
you know I wanted you can if you're not
packing shipments because you're scared
they Joey's gonna put the [ __ ] wrong
t-shirt in for Carol yeah for sure and
yeah that's it like that I know you'd
like it I was super like you know like
what's fun and the way you know and I
think people know this cuz it rolls so
fast up here a lot of times I cut off
but something but most of time actually
don't but I can see where the path is
going so I couldn't wait till we got to
this money moment cuz I'm like this kids
really about to take off because once I
dropped this [ __ ] jewel in his pocket
he's gonna [ __ ] fly because when you
love the process which I know you do
because I'm listening you start not
caring as much about the money a lot of
people care too much about the money and
they're like [ __ ] if Joey sends it to
Carol and I got a reship it I'm gonna
loop it that's [ __ ] small lack of
abundance mentality but no care about
that and when you care about your
reputation but you realize when you call
[ __ ] Carolyn like Carol this is AJ I'm
so sorry yeah believe it or not my buddy
who's like hung over scared she's gonna
lose her mind the I'm sorry's been
even if the [ __ ] t-shirt got there on
time yeah that's true no you're gonna do
that yeah that's awesome thank you so
much you're welcome so much we and AJ
this was so fun for me you write the
book it's so right it helps somebody
like you pop off then there's a show you
come on I'll give you another nugget six
years from now you know you'll listen to
me out of podcast and it will be the
next nugget you know I it's so funny I
was so excited to being the whiz kid
when I was in my game I always wondered
what it would feel like to get older
like you know because I love sports so
much oh my god you know it must like I
love the climb right but it's I've been
unbelievable how enjoy how much
enjoyment I get from being a little bit
more of the Yoda instead of the Anakin
you know and one of the things that I
really appreciate about you is obviously
your importance of family importance
with you know taking care of yourself
and deep down right we're just meant to
live simply and love people and whatever
but just like you I'm extremely
competitive you know I want to do
something right and so you will bro I
can say it already I'm so confident
about that I can smell it thank you yeah
just now add patience okay I mean I
thing I'm 22 right I mean like I was
literally a cashier at 22 I'm being dead
[ __ ] serious yeah I mean I found my
thing maybe two years ago and you know
been doing it every day and I got this
bro you got this I'm proud of you I
really yeah me bye bye all right tea
squad thank you so much being on the
show definitely sign up for a wine text
if you buy wine at all if you drink wine
at all sign up for wine text today's
offer is actually bananas and and I just
hope you had a good time as much as I
did we're really doing things out here
this was a really good show
I just really truly appreciate this
community a lot I hope you got as much
uh
I hope it got as much as I thought came
out of the show good show I love you all
so much take care of sports cards crew
get educated you can lose a lot of money
in sports cards even as hot as it is if
you're not educated education patients
see ya